[Music]
it's over sort of for now the Senate is
about to pass a spending bill to end the
three-day government shutdown the
legislation goes next to the house and
then the president will sign it leaders
on both sides finally reached a deal to
end the stalemate earlier it's only
temporary though it's a short-term
measure to fund the government through
February 8 Democrats ended up caving but
that's not how Minority Leader Chuck
Schumer sees it the reason the
Republican majority had such difficulty
finding consensus is they could never
get a firm grip on what the president of
their party wanted to do these days you
never know who to deal with when it
comes to the Republicans President Trump
turned away from not one but two
bipartisan compromises each would have
averted this shutdown president Trump's
unwillingness to compromise caused the
Trump shutdown and brought us to this
moment the Trump shutdown will soon end
but the work must go on and it will we
have word that the Senate has just
passed the bill and President Trump
earlier said he's pleased that Democrats
have finally come to their senses what
the president did clearly worked that
vote just came in 81 to 18 I would say
that those numbers are much more in the
president's favor than in Senator
Schumer's favor I'm not sure what
changed for him and what he gained other
than maybe Nancy Pelosi taking a bunch
of Republican members out for dinner to
celebrate their shutdown I'm not sure
what other positive things came out of
this weekend for Democrats as for
dreamers who still don't know what their
fate is with immigration unresolved
here's what the White House says I think
that they should storm Capitol Hill and
protest there because that is the place
that has held up this discussion
Democrats are the one that shut this
discussion down by forcing a government
shutdown all right Greg I'll go to you
first for anything you want to talk
about but I would tee up that senator
phil gramm former senator used to say
don't take a hostage you're not willing
to shoot oh that's what I had not agree
more with the Democrats but we have
another thing we need to address well
what's on my head
three minutes before we walked in here
the door open and hit me in the head
pretty good yeah yeah I am it's pretty
good it was basically a three-day
weekend
for the shutdown it was like you know it
wasn't really a shutdown I was like a
supermarket where one aisle is closed
you know and then everybody's back to
business I think the mistake that the
Democrats made was taking a certain
segment of greater society ie what what
is called the dreamers though I resent
that call I think we're all dreamers and
putting them linguistically putting them
in front of a lot of people so they put
the dreamers in front of other
undocumented immigrants from other
countries they put them in front of
immigrants who are actually waiting in
line you're putting them in front of
American citizens who are waiting for
their benefits or American citizens and
the military or even fallen heroes so I
think it was a losing argument for them
to attach this to a spending bill
because you are putting American
citizens in the back seat get one it's
hard to vote against a bill because of
something that is not in it and I think
the Republicans strategically were smart
everything that they added to the CR
were things that the rapid emma-crats
liked the funding of the government the
chip money for six years and so it's
almost harder to keep basically arguing
for something that is not in there but
they did get the concession that an up
or down vote will be held on daca in the
Senate by February 8th but it's not
promised it's just a pledge there's kind
of uncertain what I what I mean by it's
not a promise it is a promise it's not
guaranteed Dana right so for the
Democrats when they when you see Chuck
Schumer up there saying hey here's what
we've done I think he's from his
position we've revealed that the
Republicans can be very hard on the
dreamers and most Americans want a deal
for the dreamers and secondly the polls
have shown that most Republicans would
have been blamed but Schumer and I think
this is particularly true for the
Democratic base caved I mean he
basically said this could look bad for
Democrats if you were to follow the kind
of spin that you know what Greg was just
saying about oh it's about the military
or it's about putting the dreamers ahead
of somebody in the government or
government functions for people who are
getting Social Security X or whatever I
don't know but the problem for Schumer
and the Democrats is the dreamers the
Hispanic Caucus I think a lot of people
in the base who just think you know
Democrats are just spec less well in a
way Jesse I wonder about the Democrats
we talk about the Republicans civil war
but the Republicans actually were
remarkably united through this period
and the headlines for Democrats
especially in those red states where
they have Democratic senators that are
up for reelection it became harder for
them to swallow a lot of the headlines
that were coming their way
and she Senator Schumer sided with them
over the mark progressive part of his
party well Juan just said the Democrats
are feckless and Schumer caved I think
he's the one that got hit in the head
[Laughter]
I completely agree with both Juan and
you Dana Krong Chuck caved it was the
Schumer surrender he totally
miscalculated on Trump's core values why
would Trump blink when you're
prioritizing illegal aliens over the US
military he walked into an ambush of his
own making and now he looks weak going
forward with more negotiations
I don't think Trump comes out of this
looking bad at all he came and stood on
principle and didn't blink and now has a
stronger hand going into future
negotiations and the position that Chuck
has taken has evolved at first it was
we're not going to fund the border wall
at all then we're not gonna link daca to
the border wall funding now border wall
funding is on the table and Trump has
successfully linked wall funding to the
daca debate truck does not look good
here at all and the Democrats totally
miscalculated the polls on the issue
just because seventy percent of the
American people want to protect the
dreamers doesn't mean that's the highest
priority of the American Pope right they
said the American people are saying okay
we want to help the dreamers but don't
shut down the government because of it
and right before the show Kimberly we
found out that President Trump
apparently is currently meeting with
Senator Doug Jones the new senator from
Alabama and Senator Manchin from West
Virginia Democrats who apparently
they're talking about immigration so
maybe they're trying to figure this out
we're putting them in the reasonable
category versus upchuck who's like
puking right now at his private bath
because not coming out of this looking
good at all and not a good move but you
know this is the exactly when you deal
with like a businessman who knows how to
negotiate and now you're something
that's married together that is very
good for the Democrat so how could they
object to it so it was just like a
strategy in terms of going for it but
ultimately forget about the politics
this is good for the American people and
it's in keeping with what the voters
what people want and of course you want
to be good to people come we're a nation
of immigrants okay
but there has to be some specific
structure and guidelines set up and
there's no need for us to protect people
who are illegal immigrants that come in
here and that are criminal recidivists
and commit crimes of any nature so
President Trump this wasn't something
that he was going to give up on he was
taking a stand he also has to
politically and because it's the right
thing to do to not back off in terms of
border security and protection that is
something that was pivotal in terms of
what he ran and you have a big problem
with his base if he abandoned that so
right now it's a advantage POTUS can I
just interrupt for a second to say this
is not about Donald Trump you guys seem
to think this is a win for Donald Trump
let me just tell you a couple of things
over the weekend in Washington one the
White House answering machine saying
Democrats I've shut down the government
their response was reason we can't
answer the phone and then a 30-second ad
put out by Republicans that said
Democrats are complicit whenever an
illegal immigrant commits a crime in
fact the kind of conversations among
politicians was that guess what Trump
wasn't informed not involved in fact not
trusted in terms of further negotiations
on this that's why it came down to
something between Schumer and McConnell
I don't think by the way the American
people have lost track of the fact that
Republicans control House Senate and
White House and have not passed a budget
and still don't have a budget right now
and that it even though we picked the
can down the road to February 8th
they're gonna have to make some kind of
deal and guess who it's gonna really
wind up in terms of burden on the
shoulders Paul Ryan House Senate passes
a bill let's say February 8th it's got
to go to the house and then what is Paul
Ryan say to all of his freedom caucus
guys and if they don't do it what does
that look like for Republicans I asked
David hoppy that today he used to work
for speaker Ryan and he's
that he thinks that the speaker is
pretty happy with how things turned out
today and he's not concerned about it
but I think you know whatever happens in
this meeting today and going forward
that President Trump is having with
those Senate Democrats might make a
difference
Gregg listen to what Mitch McConnell
said earlier on the Senate floor I think
we've learned anything during this
process it's that a strategy to shut
down the government over the issue of
illegal immigration is something the
American people didn't understand and
would not have understood in the future
so I'm glad we've gotten past that and
we have a chance now to get back to work
I think one of the things is that most
people didn't pay attention into this to
this over the weekend because one the
there was a big football game that we're
gonna get to later in the show there was
but also because the shutdown doesn't
really have much of a bite until it gets
into the later days basically they've
cushioned it so much it's like a little
shutdown yeah and also we these
shutdowns we've how many have we talked
about in this show yeah we've created we
created a jaded populace yeah America
knows the drill they know that
governments like a romantic comedy the
ending is very predictable so I you know
I always wondered if there's a solution
for this and it you know like like why
do people why does this happen because
it's not a secret ballot so people cave
to peer pressure of their own party they
can't do certain things I'm certain a
lot of those Democrats would have been
happy to have voted for it earlier but
they can't you know so if you had a
blind vote on these situations would
there be better action because there's
less impact from peer pressure but on
the other hand it would be less
transparent to the voter and the voter
would never know yeah who the person but
in these in these situations you've got
you after wonder it's like what would
happen if they did that if they could
vote exactly how they felt if they voted
exactly how about ninety ten yeah
exactly yeah thoughts from you Jesse
nothing just that this was different
because the media couldn't save the
Democratic Party from the bad press of
the shutdown and this is the first time
Republicans haven't really been fully
blamed for a shutdown South
two firsts and hopefully we don't do
this brinksmanship again it's boring and
it's stupid it's common coming big so I
mean I think well yeah I'm it doing it
again remember you look at the Democrats
who did not vote to bail everything out
and guess who they are they're the ones
that are likely running for president
Camilla Harris Cory Booker Bernice and
all the smart ones from red states to
trump one they didn't vote for it on
Friday no one my favorite things about
the five yeah Kimberly is the
pronunciation police this is correct
good and I can't I liked earlier I don't
know if you caught it and I don't know
if you meant to but the Schumer
surrender